النجوم الأجانب في فريق لوك دونالد في روما سيكونون يبلغون من العمر
28 عامًا، التقى الإسباني جون رام
بطل 2023 للماسترز مع
كريستينا ماكفارلين من CNN قبل
البطولة المفتوحة لهذا العام حيث أوضح كيف يجب أن
يشكر كأس رايدر ومجموعة صداقة والده على
مسيرته المهنية في  اللعبة
التي يرى أن لعبة الجولف لم تكن شيئًا ليس
على راداره، إنها بخس
صحيح ونعم بسبب 97 الشبقية
فاز باثنين من هؤلاء
الأشخاص في مجموعة الأصدقاء الذين سمعوا
عنها ذهبوا لرؤيتها وبعد ذلك عندما
عادوا إلى المنزل و  قال إنه يتعين علينا أن
نجرب لعبة الجولف هذه، ونعم لقد
حاولوا بعد فترة وجيزة، وذلك عندما
أدخلت والدي في لعبة الجولف قبل أن لا يكون لدى
عائلتي أي اتصال بالجولف،
وكان أول من دخل
إلى ملعب الجولف
[موسيقى  ]
لذا انظر للأمام لهذا العام في
روما، أعني أنه كان هناك الكثير من
السلبية بعد
كأس رايدر الأخيرة حول فرص أوروبا في المضي
قدمًا ولكن يبدو أننا في
مكان مختلف تمامًا الآن مع
النجاح الذي حققته.  لقد حققنا النجاح الذي
حققه روري فيكتور، ما مدى قوة
فرصك في رأيك هذا العام؟ إنها
فرصة قوية، ويسعدني أن أرى في الكثير
من هؤلاء اللاعبين الذين حصلوا على أول
تجربة مثيرة، لقد لعبت بشكل
جيد حقًا بعد ذلك، وهناك فرصة جيدة
الوقت الذي يقضيه فيه ولديك مات
فيتزباتريك في بطولة كبرى في
حدث كبير هذا العام، فاز فيكتور
بحدث ضخم من الواضح أنني وروري نحافظ على
المستوى الذي كنا نلعب فيه على
اليمين، لذا لنرى كل ذلك وكل هؤلاء
اللاعبين العظماء تومي  عودة فليتوود
إلى مستوى أفضل مما كان عليه في ذلك الوقت، إنه أمر
مدهش ومع ظروف
الجولف في الوقت الحاضر ربما تم منح
الفرصة لبعض اللاعبين الأصغر سنًا الذين
لديهم حقًا اهتمام بالمشاركة في
كأس رايدر الأول، لذا
سيكون الأمر بمثابة  فريق أصغر سنًا ولكني
أعتقد أنه سيكون فريقًا جيدًا حقًا
وكذلك فرصنا
[تصفيق]
كيف يختلف الأمر عن مجرد
الحدث العادي بالنسبة لأولئك منا الذين ليسوا
في الحبال، أعني أنه يمكنك كيف
تشعر هناك  لا توجد طريقة
لتفسير مدى
اختلافها تمامًا عن أي قهوة أخرى
لدينا، إنها أقرب ما سنشعر به على الإطلاق من
الشعور بما سيشعر به
لاعب كرة قدم أثناء لعبه في
مباراة بالدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز على الملعب هو
الأقرب إلى المكان الذي نشعر فيه.  سيكون الأمر
مختلفًا تمامًا، الشاي الأول لا يشبه
أي شيء آخر،
لا أستطيع حقًا شرحه مهما كان
رأيك، دعنا نقول للاعب إسباني
مهما كان ما تعتقد
أنه سيشعر به كلاعب كرة قدم
في المعسكر رقم أو حرق الجرس
أه  اللعب لفريقك المفضل هو
نفس الشيء في حكومة الكتابة فيما يتعلق بمصطلحات
الجولف، نعم وهو أمر أكثر
إثارة للأعصاب، وهذه في الواقع
طريقة جيدة جدًا لشرح الأمر
بالخارج
[موسيقى]